PROFESSOR: Hi.
Welcome back to recitation.
You've been talking
about differentials.
And one of the things
that you've shown
is that some of the
stuff that we've
been doing with
derivatives can also
be phrased in terms
of differentials.
That for many purposes they
form a just a different language
to compute the same things.
So in particular one example of
that is linear approximation.
So I have a problem here that's
a linear approximation problem,
but I'd like you to do it using
the method of differentials.
So in particular I'd like you
to approximate the square root
of 21.
And the way I'd like
you to do that is
by using a linear
approximation to the function
f of x equals the square root
of 10x minus x squared based
at the point 2, x_0 equals 2.
Note that, you know,
why are we using
this function to approximate
square root of 21?
Well because at 3, the
function value at 3, f of 3,
is exactly equal to
the square root of 21.
So to approximate
the square root
21 means approximate
the function value at 3.
And so, you know, this function
has a nice value at x equals 2,
so we can use linear
approximation at 2
to try and compute
an approximation
to the function at x equals 3.
So why don't you take a couple
of minutes, work this out,
come back and we can
work it out together.
All right, welcome back.
So we're doing linear
approximation here.
And we're doing it
with differentials.
So, in general, when we use
the method of differentials
to compute a linear
approximation, what we have is
that if y equals f of x, so if
y is given as a function of x,
then we have that-- so if we
want to change x a little bit
and figure out what
the change in y is,
we have this formula,
which is that f
of x plus dx-- so the function
value at a nearby point--
is approximately
equal to y plus dy.
So this is our formula
for linear approximation
in terms of differentials.
So in our case we have that
our-- that the point we want
is x equals 2 and y equals 4.
And so we have, we
know what dx is also,
because we want the
approximation at the point 3.
So we want dx to be equal
to 1 for this approximation.
And so the question is,
what is dy going to be?
So that's the value
that we're after.
That tells us how much the
function value changes.
So to compute dy, well dy is the
differential of the function.
So this is d of the
square root of 10x
minus x squared, quantity.
OK, so to compute
this differential now,
we just use our straight-forward
rules for doing this.
So we take a derivative and then
we have dx's where necessary.
So this is d of square root
of 10x minus x squared.
So the outermost function
is the square root function.
So this is going to be
1/2 times 10x minus x
squared to the minus 1/2.
So that's 1 over the square
root of 10x minus x squared.
And now I need to
multiply by the derivative
of the inside function,
which is 10 minus 2x dx.
So really it's 10dx minus
2x*dx but I just, you know,
pulled that dx out in front.
So we have a differential
equal to a differential.
OK, and so, but
we want this value
at this particular
point in question.
So at this particular
point in question
we have x equals 2
and dx is equal to 1.
So the value of dy that we
want is equal to 1/2 times--
well this is again, OK, 10 times
2 minus 2 squared, that's 16.
To the minus 1/2, times--
so here x equals 2.
10 minus 4 is 6.
Times dx is just this 1
that we're interested in.
OK so 16 to the minus
1/2, 16 to the 1/2
is 4, so 16 to the
minus 1/2 is 1/4.
So this is 1/2
times 1/4 times 6.
So that's 6/8, which is 3/4.
So our dy is 3/4.
So that means our
linear approximation
that we're after is just
f of 3, f of x plus dx
is approximately
equal to our value y
that we, at our original point,
which was 4, plus the dy.
So plus 3/4.
So the linear
approximation that we
get from this method
of differentials
is exactly the
same approximation
that we would get if we
did this the other way.
But I think it's
kind of nice to do it
in this differential form.
Somehow it seems a little more
straightforward sometimes.
And OK, and so the answer that
we get out of it is 4 plus 3/4.
All right, so that's that.